foreign
out in Philadelphia
Samantha what are you doing
I'm just waiting to talk to you John
awesome so being a caller is it weird
listening to all the shenanigans behind
the scenes or is it just exactly what
you thought it was going to be
um it's what I thought it was going to
be but it's still a little weird very
cool uh okay so what's up what's going
on
um so I'll go straight to my question
um my question is how do I support a
friend who cheated on her husband
without enabling her decision
tell me more
okay so it's a really close friend like
we grew up together super close and she
cheated on her husband and I guess a
little more that I found out since I put
the call question in is that she hasn't
told the husband the extent to her
cheating so there's that I know you
always say Secrets destroy things but
it's not my secret to tell so I'm
struggling with a how to support her and
be like we hang out with them all the
time so it's weird yes Secrets destroyed
and so does sleeping with your husband's
friend right so both of those things
both of those things hurt marriage oh
man okay so
how did how did she how does she tell
you how did this come to you
um so
so touch base there to see like how
things were going it kind of just like
came out as word vomit
so it was like this hour-long phone call
and then after we get through it all
like her husband found the text messages
thought it was just emotional and then
as we're ending the phone call she goes
oh I actually slept with him too and I
was like oh
so it was just I didn't know what to say
so what has happened since then how did
you find out that she hasn't told her
husband yet yeah so
honestly in which he doesn't want to go
to he's just kind of rug sweeping the
situation
like wants to move past it so it's like
obviously never gonna come up if he
never goes to therapy and she never says
anything
um
So when you say enabling what do you
mean by that
um so so I wanna support obviously like
she's my best friend but also like so
she says these like weird things to kind
of justify her cheating and obviously
I'm a big time listener so like no one
else makes you make the choices you
decide like you decide that and I don't
know how to like get that through her
head that no matter what her husband did
to her like it's not his fault
so
I've had moments in my life when I have
close friends
and they do something
they
um violate my trust in a way
that makes me wonder
if you can do that in this situation
what would you do with my trust
what would you do with our relationship
and the moment and this is this is just
me the moment I go there
often there's a turning point in that
relationship from that point forward
it's different
and
just personally speaking
um I think I've told this on on the show
before and if I haven't if I have um I
guess it's worth repeating uh one time I
was sitting down with a group of guys
and I had moved to a new city and my
wife had was finishing up her
dissertation research so she was going
to move six months later and so we were
just gonna hang out on the weekends it
was about three hours away from each
other so after about two months I was
hanging out with this group of guys and
they had been really kind and welcomed
me in and several of them I'm still
super close to to this day and
we were all making jokes and just being
stupid guys sitting around a table
um and I said they said hey do you need
anything and I was like well man I'm
super lonely if anyone knows of any
girlfriends here in this new city
totally kidding and one guy his name's
Kevin
one of my closest friends said
um hey you don't know us that well and
so just so we're super clear
if you ever cheat on your wife you
better hope to God she finds you before
we do
and it was a very like this is who we
are and this is how we're gonna roll
now I know some of the people in that
group have have they've walked through
infidelity with each other they've
walked through all kind of crazy stuff
together
the difference is and and again
everyone's got their own opinions on
this this is just me I have worked in
student conduct long enough I've sat
with people who have done stupid things
and had bad moments and had bad weekends
I've had bad months right where they
just did things that were so out of
character and so I often tell people I
don't think character is the initial
incident
I think character is who you are after
you do something
yeah destructive right and so she's
she's she hooks up with somebody okay
that happens in my world with dealing
with people who are married that happens
it happens it happens
you're getting to see in real time who
she is on the back end of doing
something that could potentially be
devastating to somebody that she says
she loves
and that is I'm gonna lie I'm gonna hide
it I'm gonna bury it and I'm gonna hand
it to my friend to Carrie
and bring her drag her through all this
see what I'm saying and so for me the
enabling is is not about the marriage
thing you can't you can no more do
anything about that
unless you just felt so compelled I've
got a few friends that their wives are
basically equally as close and I would
say hey we're gonna have this
conversation and I'll do it with you but
I'm not holding the secret for you but
that's just very very few the rest of
them and I mean that's
but I'm not gonna hang out with you I'm
gonna opt out of this relationship right
not because you did a thing one time not
because you did a thing over a period of
a few months or whatever
it's because you showed your true colors
your true character on the back end of
this mistake and you've continued to
blame other people you've continued to
pass the buck you've continued to lie
about it does that make sense
yeah I know that that hits hard but it's
true and so
um the you've heard me say this it's not
by your hand but in your lap you had a
really close friend who did a thing and
then it's dragged you along through the
deception and the dishonesty and if I'm
you I'm not going along on that ride
yeah and I think that may it can be as
easy as I'm just not going to return
your text anymore or calls anymore
or it can be as direct and honest as
taking her to coffee and saying hey I I
can't be a part of this because I feel
like I'm getting dragged through it
because I know something when we sit
down as a fam as a couple you know we're
all sitting down I know something he
doesn't know and I can't I can't be a
part of that I can't
and she's gonna call you every name in
the book and blah that's cool
but as far as I'm concerned she didn't
get a vote anymore
yeah
that's kind of how I've been feeling
like I think about it you know and my
husband I talk about it and we're just
like it's just awkward like we just hang
out with them and it's just awkward
super awkward
for real it's awkward so
um what is that you know her and you
know how she would hear things
um
there's people in my life who I love
that we've been places and I'd say hey
give me your keys I'm driving home and I
know I'm gonna have to go ask this guy
for his keys it's gonna be a fight
no bro I'm flying up he's not driving
you're not driving home and then there's
others that are more than happy to hand
the keys over how is this conversation
gonna go
um it'll be the fight okay
yeah I mean I I think though she needs
to hear it because everyone else is just
kind of like either a doesn't know the
full information so they're like he's
being irrational about everything like
her husband or like
be like just cuddling her and just being
like it's okay get through it so I don't
think anyone has really like had the I
don't want to say courage because I
don't think it's the courageous thing
it's just like been truthful and
straightforward with her
I think the truth and
straightforwardness has to be about you
though
yeah otherwise it becomes you throwing
grenades at somebody and I just I'm not
participating in that very often
occasionally I'll say hey you're you've
heard the show enough like occasionally
very if you go back and listen to it
carefully it's rare that I say this is a
terrible person
usually I'm an OG listener okay so I've
never really heard you say that it's
rare that I I find that like you're an
awful human and you don't deserve to be
around usually it's people have because
of particular Pathways they've ended up
in a place that nobody wants to be in
and they don't know how to get out and
that happens
um
do do
this one's a mess I I just I I I I would
sit down and say I can't participate in
this anymore this makes it about you I'm
uncomfortable sitting down at a table
with your husband and you and acting
like everything's normal because it's
not everything's in ashes and y'all are
just playing and so I don't want to
participate in this and not make it
about you cheated and you're this and
you're a liar I wouldn't go that route
make it about you and then walk away
yeah short sweet and to the point which
is so hard I know I know that's so hard
but it's honestly knowing her person
will have her
runs out one of my core core um
core beliefs is or core actions I guess
is I only speak to be heard I don't
speak to just who so I can have said
something right I get a lot of heat on
the internets for not responding to
every thing that goes on in the world
and
um if things are super volatile and
political and nonsensical I'm not gonna
be heard they just people just want to
find out what team I'm on and so for
this I'm gonna speak in a way that can
be heard and that is I am choosing to
not be around you right now
and I think it's also fair to say I love
you and I will walk through hell with
you
if you're willing to walk through hell
but if you're willing if you're just
gonna try to avoid the whole thing I'm
not I'm not taking that route with you
I really like that is that cool
I really appreciate that sorry that
happened to you man that's such a bummer
man we want our friends who especially
our Rider dies to have our same values
and not do stupid things and when they
do do stupid things to come to us and
say hey walk with me through
the reconciliation through this stupid
thing or walk with me through the next
chapter and phase of My Life
um
and I've got close friends that I love
and I'll say what you're doing is really
stupid you can come stay at my house and
uh your wife can come stay at my house
or your ex can come stay at my house
you're welcome here but I'm telling you
I think what you're doing is dumb
because you asked me
um and so I'm really honest with folks
but
sorry I wish it was a great outcome here
I don't see it being super great
it may be in the long term though it may
be that your words and your honesty and
your directness and your friendship and
the way you love your friend and holder
accountable
in this wacky accountable free world we
live in now might be
the somebody ripping back the curtains
in the shades and letting the light in
that she really needs thank you for
loving her